so I'd like to talk about three infinite
series so sums of infinitely many
numbers so here's the first one 1 plus
1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 plus blah blah
blah what's that and the answer is it's
2 this is the problem of Achilles and
the tortoise Achilles is to Stadio or
whatever the unit of length is in
ancient Greece from The Tortoise well
after a while
Achilles gains on the tortoise one unit
and so the remaining distance is only 1
then after a while Achilles gains half
of the distance to the tortoise and now
the distance to the tortoise is 1/2
after a little while Achilles gains
another 1/4 of the distance to the
tortoise and so on and so on and so on
the story according to Zeno's paradoxes
is that achilles never catches the
tortoise well of course
achilles never catches the tortoise at
any of these times but if you just wait
a little longer Achilles will have
caught the tortoise the total length
that Achilles gains on the tortoise is 2
and that's why this is true now let's
look at 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/3 plus 1/4
plus 1/5 plus 1/6 plus 1/7 plus 1/8 and
so on and this never ends how big is
that what is that what I mean is if I
stop after many many many terms so I can
so I'm adding some huge finite list of
numbers how big is that and what happens
when I add more and more and more of
them and the answer is this is infinity
why well let me group the terms here's
the first one here are the next two here
are the next for the next eight would
end with 1 over 15 and this goes on
forever I don't want to mark up my desk
well so what exactly does this mean you
give me any number at all 50 trillion
and I can stop this series and say ok I
will only go this far I'm adding only a
finite number of numbers together but
that sum will be more than
D trillion that's true not only for 50
trillion but for any number you name no
matter how big and that's what it means
that the sum of the series is infinity
so it's blowing up it's like exactly
exactly we say that the series diverges
so let's look at the first term well
it's 1 thank you how about these next
two terms well you know what this one is
bigger than 1/2 each one of these terms
is bigger than 1/4 1/2 is bigger than
1/4 1/3 is bigger than 1/4 and there are
two terms so this is bigger than 2/4
which is again 1/2 how about these four
terms they're all bigger than 1/8 and
there are 4 of them so if I add these
guys it's bigger than 4 eighths which is
1/2 if I look at the next eight terms
they're all bigger than 1/16 and they're
eight of them so the sum is bigger than
8/16 which is 1/2 if I stop far enough
this sum will be more than 1/2 plus 1/2
plus 1/2 plus 1/2 plus 1/2 and I can go
on as many times as I like accumulating
what have until I get to more than 50
trillion so sooner or later the sum of
these numbers will be more than 50
trillion the catch is that I have to go
enormous ly far out in order to do it
but let's not worry about that now okay
never mind just how enormous that's
let's leave it there for this sum which
has a name it's called the harmonic
series I'd like to explain how to use
the harmonic series to stack dominoes
well actually I don't have dominoes in
my office but I have lots of issues of
the annals of mathematics oh yes I have
lots and lots and lots so we're going to
use copies of the annals of mathematics
as dominoes let's just take two of them
first if I move this one here it's going
to collapse but if I move it so that its
center of gravity is let's see if that
works I'm being a little conservative
the center of gravity of this guy
is sitting over that guy and so it does
not collapse now let's take these two
and put them very carefully on top of
the third one taking care that the
center of gravity of this whole guy is
above this issue of the annals of
mathematics and therefore looks
precarious ok there it does not collapse
and now perhaps I could put these three
on top of a fourth and if I succeed in
doing that I will not tempt fate I will
just declare that that we have succeeded
whoop so let's see how are we doing it
hasn't collapsed mm-hmm
looks a little flaky it hasn't collapsed
how far can we make this guy stick out
suppose that I have all those copies of
the annals of mathematics or perhaps all
the copies of the annals of mathematics
ever printed from the beginning of time
to the end of time wonder how many that
will be anyway we have all of them and
we stack them up and we demand that the
pile cannot collapse well this is merely
paper so sooner or later if there's too
much of a load it will be crushed but
nevermind these are imaginary rigid
Domino's can we ever make the top guy so
far out that it is not resting on the
bottom guy at all that this edge is not
lying at all over this book but has come
out farther exactly and the answer is oh
yes in fact you can make this this pile
come out in that direction as far as you
like because if you look at it but if
you have any copies of the annals of
mathematics and you do an absolutely
perfect job in an ideal world the
distances that they are slid out from
one another are in the proportions 1/2
1/2 to 1/3 to 1/4 to 1/5 to 1/6 and so
on to one over N if there are n copies
of the annals of math or maybe n plus
one copies of the annals of math and so
the fact that the harmonic series
diverges tells you that you can
eventually make this pile come out as
far as you like because 1 plus 1/2 plus
1/3 plus 1/4 plus and so on if
you stop way way far out after a
gazillion for a large enough value of a
gazillion will be more than 50 billion
and therefore this distance out there
will be more than 50 billion times the
height of the annals of mathematics all
right let's put the annals of
mathematics aside now let's do the same
thing to the series 1 plus 1/2 squared
plus 1/3 squared plus 1/4 squared plus
let me keep going squared ok blah blah
now let's try to do the same thing we're
gonna take the first term all right so
that's 1 thank you let's look at the
next two terms now this is 1 over 1/2
squared this is smaller than 1 over 1/2
squared so we've got two terms and
they're each smaller than 1/2 times 1/2
so that's smaller than 2 times 1/2 times
1/2 that's smaller than 1/2 let's look
at the next four terms here they are
they're all 1 over 4 squared or smaller
so they are smaller than 1/4 squared
plus 1/4 squared plus 1/4 squared plus
1/4 squared
there are 4 terms there and so these
guys together are no bigger than 4 times
1/4 squared that's 4 times 1/4 times 1/4
and that's 1/4 so this whole thing is
less than 1/4 if I looked at the next
eight terms and played the same game I
would find that that's less than 1/8 and
so on so now look if I go out to a
gazillion terms I'm guaranteed that what
I've got is less than 1 plus 1/2 plus
1/4 plus 1/8 plus 1/16 plus
something-or-other I stopped at 1 over
some power of 2 hey wait a minute
remember first result this series never
be the sum of these guys is never more
than 2 the sum of all these numbers is 2
and the sum of the first gazillion
numbers will be slightly less than 2 so
therefore I'm guaranteed that no matter
how many terms of this guy I take it
will be less than 2 so it doesn't run
off to infinity the
the harmonic series does and in fact you
could wonder what is the value of the
sum of all of these terms and that was a
famous unsolved problem of the 18th
century and the answer is PI squared
over 6 pi creeps in where you would
least expect it I was exactly here this
place and I was having an interview than
the phone rings hello
and the voice was saying hello this is
Las Navas from Budapest